the m2 put there is my brother
there for me there is an
unusual researcher for just the subject
but by his social conscience
to ensure that the application of
research is useful to all of
society
thanks to his science  but also thanks to
its humanist side,
technological progress, but in
particular in artificial intelligence,
gives us an incredible opportunity
we have a critical mass of researchers
who are unique in the world in this field and
we have the possibility of becoming an economic leader
and if we  made for the profits that
will be created by the new
services and new products that will
come in part from the research we
do will go into the pockets of
foreign companies
it would be a shame to miss this
opportunity
I arrived in the middle of the crisis of the
ice
and if the choice who came to pick me up
at the airport he wrote me washing I do
n't know if to see him pick you up there is
a tree that has just fallen  on my
car
for years there are many of
our students once they had
their doctorate there but he was leaving california
on the ground and then we are starting to see some
who are coming back to
montreal
I think that from the start it  is a
passionate researcher he was passionate
about research we met wanted to
talk about development projects
there was a curiosity
me when I travel in fact people from
other cities other countries ask me
what makes Montreal tick what
'we can imitate here to attract
the best researchers the best
students and industrial laboratories
all to believe that it has
really entered the 4th
industrial era it creates a revolution not
only in the
research process but also in all the
organizations that  are going to use these
technologies loeb is the first time
that you arrived in the
labs moreover choice it was a dirty
compared to the thousand ha which is  a weapon
now there was a computer for
three students that's how i
started i think it also
also catches the ear of political decision makers
at all levels whether it
is with the city of montreal with
the provincial government  or federal it
opens up portraits that we have
both found a way to share
the science on which we are working with
obviously different means but I
think of course when we ask about our
choices and he will say that it is rather the
beginning and I think he is right
the core here the damaged prince tidjani
[Music]
but camilla and high time in pipe at the x
men in biesheim
oddo
[Music]